[Music] it's 50 cents 42nd birthday yo fish first off I want to say happy birthday and he got a pretty priceless gift the gift of M&M wrappings hustle hard money step silly that's them going in on his favorite 50 verse ever that made me want to stop rapping for like a long time it's from the song places to go off the 8 mile soundtrack I want to remind you what a verse you did there made me want to quit rapping picture perfect picture picture me in a pimp a fix me coming up rich from read picture me blowing up now picture me going back 50 loved ends renditions so much he posted it to Instagram and wrote in the caption Thank You Eminem you know you're still the best in the world to me man I love you bro the duo have collaborated many times but it's 2017 and fans are over here like so if you're ready for more of this tweet me I'm at her name is Deidre 56 so much any benefit I'm out of here you [Music]